l'époque des emballages plastiques sur
les fruits et légumes bientôt révolu
promulguée le 10 février 2020 la loi
anti gaspillage sera effective le 1er
janvier 2022 et va changer beaucoup de
choses notamment pour les producteurs
visant à supprimer l'ensemble des
plastiques de notre quotidien
la loi s'attaque principalement aux
emballages des fruits et légumes vendus
en grande surface à moissac dans le tarn
et garonne
la nouvelle loi rend furieux d'autant
plus qu'aucun producteur n'a été
consulté nous avons été au pied du mur
ou une ministre après une décision un
jour sans consultation et sans nous
donner le temps de l'adaptation est
aujourd'hui il va y avoir des
conséquences importantes dans notre
filière et sans avoir aussi tenu compte
que ça fait cinq six ans qu'on est déjà
sur le sujet où dès qu'on a pu sortir le
plastique des emballages nous l'avons
fait et sur les petits les emballages
c'est un peu plus dur un peu plus long
un changement conséquent pour les
producteurs car c'est tout un système de
production qui va devoir être modifiés
l'ensemble des lignes de production et
d'emballage va même devenir désuet
alors que les grandes surfaces refuse le
vrac des options déjà été réfléchi comme
la barquette en carton les producteurs
regrette toutefois le manque de temps
pour s'adapter et s'alarme sur le futur
manque à gagner le problème d'une loin
c'est que quand ça va trop vite et qu'on
n'a pas le temps
ici on ne sait pas comment va être la
réaction du consommateur
il va voir beaucoup moins le free est ce
que il va être attiré par la barquette
comment on fait pour pour que vraiment
on est la même chose que sur l'ancien il
nous faut du temps et c'est ce temps là
qui nous a été refusé par cette loi
hajek
il reste donc moins d'un an aux
coopératives agricoles pour trouver une
solution
un emballage valorisant le produit et le
laissant visibles un défi de taille pour
les producteurs